Incapables de produire leurs propres toxines,
ces femelles boivent le sang
d'autres lucioles pour se protéger.
Ainsi, nous avons des lucioles-vampires
créées par la sélection naturelle.
Nous avons encore beaucoup à apprendre des lucioles
mais il semblerait qu'un nombre d'histoires resteront inconnues
car dans le monde, les populations de lucioles
sont en train de s'éteindre.
La première cause : la perte de leur habitat.
Un peu partout, les champs et les forêts,
les mangroves et prairies, dont ont besoin les lucioles,
cèdent place au développement et à l'extension urbaine.
Un autre problème : nous avons conquis l'obscurité,
mais en même temps, nous répandons trop de lumière la nuit,
ce qui perturbe la vie d'autres créatures.
Et les lucioles sont très sensibles à la pollution lumineuse,
parce qu'elle interfère avec les signaux
émis pour trouver leurs partenaires.
Avons-nous vraiment besoin des lucioles ?
Après tout, elles sont une si petite partie
de la biodiversité de la Terre.
Pourtant, chaque fois qu'une espèce disparait,
c'est comme éteindre une salle remplie de bougies
une par une.
Vous ne remarquerez pas
lorsque les premières flammes s’éteindront,
mais à la fin, vous resterez assis dans le noir.
Comme nous travaillons ensemble pour concevoir l'avenir de notre planète
j'espère que nous trouverons une solution
pour garder ces lumières brillantes.
Merci.
(Applaudissement)